[Applaus]
ich muss ich muss mit ihnen noch mal über
die über die Ausgewogenheit der Sendung
sprechen ja ich weiß die Ausgewogenheit
war jetzt ein bisschen weil der der
Uthoff hat leider so starke Reflexe ja dann
dann kontern sie doch mit Fakten ja Zahlen
ich meine sie machen das auch immer so super da
an der Tafel ja danke schön ich habe da auch ein
paar ganz interessante Zahlen für sich das würde
ich niemals zeigen kann aber die Polizei Zahlen
übernehmen wir sind ja immer nur die Anstalten
ne so machen alle im Fernsehen gut wenn Sie
die Zahlen nicht von der Polizei haben wollen
dann vielleicht von der Polizei Gewerkschaft
Gewerkschaft das ist doch was für Sie oder
ja ja wir haben die Daten nämlich von BKA
auf einer Staatsanwaltschaft sehr griffig
ich sag mal gestaltet ja das zeige ich
Ihnen mal hier schauen Sie also hier links
sieht man wie viele Polizeibeamte 2021 laut
Staatsanwaltschaft unrechtmäßig Gewalt
angewendet haben ja das waren 61 so und
hier rechts sieht man wie viele Polizistinnen
selber Opfer von Gewalt geworden sind Achtung
nämlich 88.626 Herr von Wagner so habe ich das
noch nie gesehen wisst ihr was ich verspreche
ich werde jetzt mal dass das sagen wir mal den
den Einsatz der Polizei ins rechte ich werde
mal den Einsatz der Polizei würdigen dreimal
dürfen Sie raten Herr von Wagner warum es in
dieser Statistik so wenig Fälle von Polizei
Gewalt gibt weil die Polizei den Anzeigen
gegen sich selbst nicht richtig nachgehen die
Polizei nimmt natürlich keinen Einfluss auf
die Ermittlungen nein warum soll die Polizei das
machen nur weil die Polizei darüber entscheidet
wie die Polizei mit den Anzeigen der Polizei die
gegen die Polizei bei der Polizei eingehen Polizei
sie haben eine Tafel vorbereitet ja darf
ich das nicht ich weiß nicht darf er das
also ordnungsrechtlich weiß ich leider nicht
was dagegen spricht er spricht dagegen er
kann doch nicht in aller Öffentlichkeit
behaupten dass die Polizei nicht richtig
gegen sich selbst ermittelt ich kann
das sogar beweisen rüber sie spielen
jetzt mal die Polizei hier bitte schön
ich habe sogar einen Dienstausweis für
sie ja okay Kriminalhauptkommissar
immerhin ja Viktor Schlagstock
Polizeidienststelle Cloppenburg
veilchenweg 7 sie lösen jetzt mal diesen
Fall von Polizei Gewalt nicht wahr ist
geht's hier schon mal ein bisschen wie also
das ist hier was ist das weiße Kreide oder
alles muss man selber machen
so okay was haben sie mir jetzt schon na
gut das ist ein relativ einfacher Fall hier
hat die Polizei ja offensichtlich Gewalt
angewendet und quasi sich strafbar gemacht
hier was ist was haben wir hier ah ja Paragraph
340 Strafgesetzbuch ja das ist also quasi der
Körperverletzung im Amt ja worauf stützen sie denn
ihre Vermutung vermutlich auf Fotos das ist das
Opfer sind offensichtlich und Jochbeinbruch ja
und und mehrere Prellungen sagt aus das ist auf
offener Straße von uniformierten verprügelt
worden ist auch die Feuerwehr gewesen sein
ich kenne doch diese Mütze das ist dieselbe Mütze
war die Polizei die Polizei bisschen unspezifisch
verschwinden sie nicht die Polizei hat 300.000
Mitarbeiter davon Wagner wer war's denn ja mit
der Mütze also gut das Warten sie warten sie
wir leben in einem Rechtsstaat ja wir haben
Kennzeichen der Uniform so Kennzeichnungspflicht
da wird die Polizei ermittelt haben dass dieses
Kennzeichen dieses Kennzeichen scheint
nicht hier drin zu sein vielleicht hat das
Opfer beim verprügelt werden vergessen
mitzuschreiben oder das hat sich zu sehr
auf seinen Jochbeinbruch konzentriert oder der
Vorfall ist eine dem einen der Bundesländer
passiert die hier rot markiert sind da konnte das
Opfer gar nicht mitschreiben in den Bundesländern
gibt es nämlich gar keine kennzeichnungspflichte
keine Kennzeichen in allen Bundesländer krass ich
meine da werden diese Länder doch bestimmt gute
Gründe für haben natürlich sind das gute Gründe
ja laut im Innenminister von Nordrhein-Westfalen
Herbert Reul ist die Kennzeichnungspflicht für
Polizeibeamten eine Äußerung von Misstrauen
ja das heißt wir würden die Polizeibeamten
stigmatisieren die dafür sorgen dass wir alle
in Sicherheit leben können Kfz-Kennzeichen ich
bin ja auch Träger eines Kfz-Kennzeichen und
ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht stigmatisiert
ja laut unseren Unterlagen sorgen sie mit
ihren Fahrstil ja auch dich für Sicherheit
sie können den Täter also nicht ermitteln Herr
von Wagner oder also ich wissen Sie was sind
Fällen wie die in ihren die einzige Chance ist
in aufzuklären das ist überraschend auftauchendes
Videomaterial und wo soll es herkommen ja
von Wagner es ist überraschend Videomaterial
aufgetaucht hör doch es ist überraschend
Videomaterial aufgetaucht immer können Sie das
technisch zusammen anschauen können nein Stopp das
öffentliche vorführen der Polizei verstößt gegen
Paragraph 22 Kunst Urheberrecht war es geht hier
um das Recht der Polizei an ihrem eigenen Bild
haben sie damit gerade zugegeben dass die Polizei
also Urheber ist dieses Kunstwerkes ja das war
ihre blaue Phase und Sie hören jetzt mal auf zu
filmen warum das denn eine Genehmigung bräuchten
wir nur wenn wir das öffentlich ausstrahlen
würden und das hier das läuft nach 22 Uhr
im ZDF das guckt keine Sau ganz kurz ich bin
verwirrt dürfen wir jetzt Polizei Ermittlungen
hier also beim Einsatz dürfen wir jetzt Filmen
201 Strafgesetzbuch verbietet Aufnahmen Ton und
Filmaufnahmen ohne Zustimmung in privaten Räumen
aha in privaten schauen sie mein Opfer ist ja
auf offener Straße verprügelt worden nee Herr von
Wagner wenn ihnen ein Polizeibeamte zwischen die
Beine tritt ja dann ist das ihre Intimsphäre
und die ist natürlich geschützt [Gelächter]
sagen Sie mal sie haben doch auch so so Kameras
da gell ja und ja wir haben mittlerweile fast in
allen Bundesländern bodycamps dann haben doch
auch die Beamten die hier dabei waren bodycams
getragen wir nehmen das Material gelöst das
sind ganz spezielle Kameras die irgendwie nur
Gewalt gegen die Polizisten aufnehmen ja sonst
hätten hey Freundchen das war privat das wird
nicht gefilmt wie soll das denn funktionieren
doch immer an das ist doch nicht das bloß weil
der Tag eines Polizeibeamten Sie sich mal
zu mal in den unglaubliche Gewalt steigert
aus Versehen vielleicht leider schaltet sich die
Body kennt doch nicht einfach ab nein selber was
ja wir haben jetzt auch nicht unendlich
Speicherkapazität ja und uns passiert ja
auch nicht immer was spannendes ja genau das ist
tot langweilig ne genau wie in Mannheim letztes
Jahr ne da ist ein Mann bei einer Polizei
Kontrolle ums Leben gekommen die bodycams
beider Polizisten vor Ort ausgeschaltet oder
letzten März in Regensburg na da ist bei einer
Festnahme man ums Leben gekommen die bodycams
ausgeschaltet oder im September die Dortmunder
Polizei erschießen jungen geflüchteten mit fünf
Schüssen aus der Maschinenpistole die bodycams
ausgeschaltet so die beiden Beamten haben ganz
hart nach dem Gesetz gehandelt ja völlig klar
denn die bodycam die wird nur eingeschaltet
wenn wirklich lebensgefahr besteht die sind tot
für den Polizisten ja also das Berühren wir
uns mal wirklich vorstellen dass das wirklich
so ist es würde ja bedeuten dass er quasi aktiv
die Aufklärung von Fällen behindert das wäre ja
quasi eine strafe-, das kann nicht sein da müsste
er quasi jemand die Polizei rufen oh Hilfe Polizei
der hat mich auf den Fuß getreten was sie
sie hat mir auf dem Fuß getreten das kann
sie nicht beweisen sie haben so eine body
kennen gedacht sofort beweisen die war aus
ich war ja nicht in Lebensgefahr
haben sie das haben sie das mitgefilmt ja
Speicher ist voll zu viel Polizei Gewalt aber
wir laufen hier Ermittlungen Herr von Wagner gut
ich verzichte auf das Videomaterial ich befrage
direkt die Polizeibeamten die einfach da dabei
waren ja brauchen Sie gar nicht die haben schon
Anzeige erstattet gegen sich selbst sehen sie
noch einmal dass der Rechtsstaat in Deutschland
nicht funktioniert gegen das Opfer eine sogenannte
konteranzeige durchaus übliches Verfahren
der Polizei bei Anzeigen gegen die Polizei
Entschuldigung was wird mit meinem Opfer denn
jetzt vorgeworfen ja Paragraph 114 Strafgesetzbuch
ein täglicher Angriff gegen Polizeibeamte
ja schauen Sie mal was der da macht ja
eine Arschbombe relativ aggressive Interpretation
schauen sie als tägliche Angriff geht jedes jede
körperaktive Bewegung des Körpers gegen
den Polizeibeamten was hat er jetzt
gedreht oder geschubst er spricht denn von solchen
Gewaltexzessen eine unabsichtliche nicht Berührung
eine unabsichtliche
nicht Berührung soll ich ihnen das
mal erklären das würde mich gerne
Kopfnuss ja das wäre gegen ein Polizeibeamten
schon eine Tätigkeit im Sinne
des Paragraph 114 strafgesetzbuch
ich wusste ja nicht dass so viel Gewalt in
mir schlummert mir werden langsam einiges
klar Mindeststrafe von drei Monaten
Haft in schweren Fällen sechs Monate
hat das gibt's normalerweise
nur für genitalverstimmungen
oder Zwangsprostitution wie muss man denn
eine angedeutete Kopfnuss anlegen damit
sie ein schwerer Fall wird sie muss von
mehreren gleichzeitig ausgeführt werden
[Gelächter] das ist natürlich nicht lustig
weil das ist natürlich trotzdem verwerflich
Beamte verwerflicher als Bürger anzugreifen weil
die Beamten stehen für den Rechtsstaat und damit
sein Angriff auf einen Beamten einen Angriff auf
uns alle seine sehr gute Einstellung danke ist
ja auch unsere durchgesetzt ein Ergebnis von
jahrelanger harter gewaltfreier Lobbyarbeit
ja bis 2011 war es nämlich noch andersrum da
ist Gewalt gegen Bürger im allgemeinen härter
bestraft worden als gegen Polizeibeamte weil man
davon ausgegangen ist dass der Bürger in Kontakt
mit den Uniformierten leichter in Wallungen zu
bringen ist immer so wie wenn man geblitzt wird
jetzt was machen Ermittlungen Anzeige
Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte
gemäß Paragraph 113 Strafgesetzbuch was
soll denn jetzt gemacht sie kommen von
ihren Gewaltfantasien offensichtlich nicht
los als widerstandsdelikte gelten bereits
alle niedrigschwelligenten Anstrengungen des
Bürgers die die diensthandlungen erschweren
das ist auch Gewalt gegen die Polizei
das hieß ja das dass jeder Polizeibeamte oder zum
Beispiel so jemanden der sich festgeklebt hat wenn
er den hochheben würde dann würde dieser Polizist
ja quasi Eingang finden in diese Statistik als als
Opfer von Gewalt ganz genau aber
das ist ja dass diese diese statist
vollkommen erklärungsbedürftig ist das ist nicht
erklärungsbedürftig die Zahl 88.000 626 die steht
für sich ich versuche meine Erklärung von
Wagner schauen Sie wenn einer etwas eine
festgeklebte Person von vier Polizisten gelöst
und weggetragen werden muss dann gehen diese
vier Polizisten als vier Opfer in die Polizei
Statistik ein obwohl es ja nur ein Fall war
bleiben 39.649 Einzelfälle die Hälfte davon ist
gar keine Gewalt sondern nur Widerstand gegen die
Vollstreckung im Sinne des Paragraphen 113 also
so ein klimakleber ganz genau die ziehen wir ab
bleiben nur noch es ist 20.602 Fälle zumeist
tägliche Angriffe darunter sehr sehr viele
Bagatelle Delikte angedeutete Kopfnüsse ganz genau
die nehmen wir auch noch weg bleiben 2576 Fälle
leichter oder schwerer Körperverletzung plus die
wirklichen Angriffe außerdem zeigt die Statistik
hier nur Verdachtsfälle die Staatsanwaltschaft
ermittelt ja grundsätzlich dies Jahr angewiesen
immer zu ermitteln bei Gewalt gegen die Polizei
ja genau wie bei den 61 Fällen von Polizei Gewalt
nein nein nein die Zahl ist ja nur deshalb
so niedrig weil die Staatsanwaltschaft in
jedem Jahr im Schnitt 90% der Verfahren einfach
einstellt dabei gab es letztes Jahr insgesamt
2790 Verfahren gegen Polizisten den
Körperverletzungen im Arm dazu kommt das Polizei
Gewalt in Wahrheit fünfmal höher eingeschätzt wird
weil die meisten Anzeigen unterlassen werden der
Menschen weil sie glauben sie haben gegen die
Polizei keine Chance dass sie sehr dass diese
beiden Zahlen im Grunde fast als als kleines
bei so vielen Zahlen schaltet ihr jeder ab
ich habe sie noch gesagt die Polizei ermittelt
nicht richtig gegen sich selbst was zu beweisen
war kein Gott kein Staat kein Geschwafel nur
der utthoff an der Tafel [Applaus] [Musik]
ja was vergessen was denn na das Abo die
Glocke was dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug